I don't know if you've gotten a chance
to hang out with with Joe when he plays
pool
I so I spent a lot of time with him when
he was playing pool like recently on
that trip to Vegas and there's something
Zen like about first of all just
watching him but I've never seen the
focus the guys got
on the game for hours
just a deep focus unshakable focus that
was so interesting to watch that this
human being he's a celebrity he does all
kinds of stuff that he's able to to
allocate
as close to 100 of his mind as I can
imagine to a particular task and nothing
can distract him that was really
inspiring that you could still do that
on any task yeah Paul is a game of
physics that should be your domain oh it
is but that wasn't just physics yeah I
would think
you understand the game you understand
the physics of it uh you also understand
the the fun of it because there's
friends and laughter and so on
I would be distracted by that a little
bit I wouldn't be as much he he
literally as the closer you get to the
table
the more it's everything Zooms in the
jokes there's funny things you can't get
his attention on anything it's that
Focus I don't know that stays that
really stuck stay with me that
like
uh you know those memes like
I want to find somebody that looks at me
the way X looks at why I want to find
somebody that looks at me the way Joe
looks at a pool cue or whatever the
focus there I want to find something in
my life
rather I want to attain the level of
focus he has
for pool on a task that I care about
and that that Focus like [ __ ] everything
else
this is now it's time to do work
um I don't know that was really
inspiring I haven't seen that kind of
focus
um
for prolonged periods of times on a task
you should see some time the guy the guy
is I mean part of this just being
competitive with himself it's the hatred
of imperfection all those kinds of
elements but embodied in a singular
Focus we had no idea even played pool
it's interesting he should we should
watch him he won't I think it it could
be one of his greatest obsessions
like there's deep uh see I thought pool
is for like degenerates
like gamblers and like Hustlers right
like uh the same way I see poker
but like I saw like a wolf's slash like
Elite athlete in Joe I said I didn't
know this I don't know much about pool I
didn't know that you could have that
level of focus while still drunk out
your ass but extremely focused it was
beautiful to see I don't know inspiring
inspiring uh for me as a person who
highly values
a singular focus on a task